my goodness we're dorking out just a
little bit it is so nice to meet you
yes let's serve up some news
sunny side up people magazine is
reporting the sexiest man alive michael
b
jordan is officially off the market i
know we're all just
right we're all sad about it but come on
they found love i know
we should be happy and look what a
gorgeous couple that is uh
lori harvey who bt dubs is steve
harvey's
daughter i just learned that me too the
two confirmed that they're
together by doing what people do now
when they announce that
they're together they become instagram
official that's the thing people do
i can't help it the whole instagram
official
like thing and the zeitgeist
you know i i don't i i just gotta get
used to it
reggae jean paige and phoebe denver
the stars of bridgette bye
we are dorking out just a little bit it
is so nice to meet you
yes you guys look amazing oh
yeah i know thank you i would have
dressed up for the occasion if i knew
i'm so sorry i feel like i've let the
side down you look just fine yeah
you're perfect and we're just doing a
little ode to your show
um you brought so much
to your characters we were all in love
at first sight
i mean that's what you want isn't it
that means so much
coming from you i mean we really are
starstruck right now
i how did you guys prepare for the role
i heard there was like
etiquette lessons by the way can you
teach us something about etiquette
yeah because we could use a tip i mean
we it was a long process we had six
weeks i mean me and regularly were both
living in l.a at the time so we both
sort of touched down
in london together to start this crazy
journey
and it was like our schedule was like
horse riding and
etiquette lessons and dance rehearsals
and
i mean it was it was kind of crazy i
think um we're all ready to
to get on the marriage mart now i feel
very fully prepared
huge news from sarah jessica parker last
night on instagram
sjp confirmed that sex in the city is
coming back
okay oh my gosh
20 21.
how excited were you when you heard this
news um beyond
we have been obsessed with sex in the
city forever and nikki and i both feel
like there still
hasn't been a show to take that place of
sex in the city so the fact that they're
coming back i'm like give me it all i
can't wait to see where the women are
going to be in their lives
we're just uh love i was literally
nursing mateo
um because we're over on pacific
standard time and i saw training
worldwide and i was like
am i just really tired or is this true
like
it's really coming it's like the gift we
all needed
there is a song that is taking over the
world right now and it's called
driver's license by have you heard it
by olivia rodrigo it's been out for less
than a week and variety says it's
already number one on
spotify apple music and amazon
uh if i actually was kind of out of the
loop on this i heard it yesterday for
the first time
okay i'm glad you got chills i'm
obsessed with it now it's been on repeat
it's about like that moment when you're
16 years old and you're in love and then
they're broken up with i'm driving by
your house you're supposed to be in my
car with me
i mean yes i understand honey listen to
me when you're 35 you'll remember this
guy's name i promise you
but it's so romantic do you remember
that feeling
uh kind of i like being older it's like
i
i loved having all the experiences but i
love the calm i feel in my body now
and since i'm woken up and no longer
dead inside then you know this is a
perfect
pretty little middle as i like to call
it women's health is reporting
you know how we became igof instagram
official
while harry and megan are becoming ig
bye bye-bye
they are saying goodbye to social media
in march of 2020 they said goodbye to
their official sussex royal ig account
but now they say they are done with the
negativity of social media
uh they're leaving and you have to feel
for somebody in their position i mean
they get a lot of hate they're famous on
like a crazy level
but it made me wonder like have you ever
thought about quitting
social media has ever been too much for
you i was very late to the game with
social media
i loved it to talk about the brands i
was working on and then
i'm glad i practiced talking to a camera
in a room by myself because i had no
idea that it would apply so much to my
new job here at the show